flexibility
[Music]
[Music]
today will be algorithms game theory and
risk-averse decision thank you dick best
thing is this microphone level okay so
in this is meant the title was mentally
the very brief introduction to
algorithms game theory discover
decision-making but as it is it's quite
long already in the past five years I've
made deliberate efforts to connect to
colleagues and researchers from flight
disciplines outside of theoretical
computer science which is where I come
from in search for interesting
algorithmic questions and so I would
typically start the conversation with
tell me what they're interesting or
important algorithmic questions in your
fields and I would get an answer search
as well find me an algorithm design an
algorithm to find the next supernova or
design an algorithm to balance the grid
or design an algorithm to incorporate
solar and renewables into the grid so
that the grid remain stable and
at this point I would draw a blank and I
would think well I don't really
understand what these problems are I
don't understand them in an algorithmic
way and I would just shy away and go
back to my old and well-known
algorithmic questions if I can make
research progress on in the sort of the
goal of this program to my understanding
is a co-organizer in the long term
participant is to help initiate or make
further progress in this dialogue
between theoreticians in my taste
theoretical computer science and our
applied domains such as a Natural
Sciences energy and transportation and I
realized that also from the past few
lectures that people outside the
theoretical computer science don't
really know what we do or what we know
what were what we're capable of doing
and to help facilitate that interaction
I would try to explain by giving a very
brief flavor of sort of given
algorithmic testing such as wine-tasting
in my mind of what algorithms what
interesting algorithms are so since this
is a workshop on real-time
decision-making
I want to start with a couple of
examples that everyone can relate to so
this is a problem that I need to solve
every day when I was back at UT Austin I
needed to go to my office every day and
I would have to decide on what is my
best route from home to the office so on
the left you see the real world map of
part of Austin and on the right is an
abstract graph instantiation of this
algorithmic problem so that's in
algorithmic terms this is called
shortest paths and everyone can relate
to that what is the shortest path from A
to B we have a very good and
that's an easy algorithmic problem a
related problem is one that UPS drivers
have to solve when they need to deliver
packages to multiple addresses and again
a map on the left and an abstract graph
representation on the right if we are
given distances between each pair of
those addresses what is the best
sequence to visit the addresses so as to
minimize the distance and the travel
time delivery time for the UPS driver so
this is another really interesting
algorithmic problem and it's a hard
problem so both of these Nathan that's
an instance of what's known as the
Traveling Salesman problem
so both the shortest path problem and
the Traveling Salesman problem are
examples of graph algorithms problems
they're both really interesting and
what's more interesting to me what's
intriguing is that one of them is easy
finding a path which is a combinatorial
object a sequence of edges in a graph
and this other one which is finding at
or it's also a sequence of edges it's
also a different kind of combinatorial
object but somehow this second object is
much harder to handle so let me go back
to very basic so what is an algorithm
it's a step by step procedure to solve a
problem many people outside of computer
science think that computer scientists
are programmers and I want to clarify
that theoretical computer scientists are
a little bit different so we are
mathematicians we think about what is
the math behind the computer algorithm
and every computer program is the
instantiation of some algorithm and for
us to be able to think productively
about what an algorithm is we need to be
faced with a general but well specified
problem so this was my challenge in my
dialogue with with colleagues outside
the field I wasn't able to get a well
specified problem in algorithmic terms
so here is a specification of the
shortest path problem I'm given a graph
G with the set of vertices V and a set
of edges E a source node s in a
destination node T in edge costs this is
the input and I want to produce as an
output a shortest SD path namely a path
with smallest total Edge cost so this to
me is now a complete algorithm
specification and I want to emphasize
again the problem he has a very clearly
specified input and a well specified
output in each such general problem his
specific instances for example we see
two different instances here one is a
portion of the map Berkley the other one
is a portion of the map of Austin with
corresponding sources and destinations
in different routes between them so an
algorithm has to be able to space it to
take every possible instance so every
possible map every possible source and
destination in Edge cost introduce an
output in this case the shortest path
with the desired properties and whenever
same problem may have many different
algorithms for solving it that may be
better some for some instances in others
for others for example diced
bellman-ford floyd-warshall are all very
famous shortest path algorithms and more
generally we like to think about the
world in abstract ways ideally as
abstract combinatorial objects so you
see here many examples of real world
situations and what the corresponding
abstract objects are so the example I
gave we had a network transportation
network and the abstraction of that was
a graph and since graphs appear a lot in
algorithms research with me
fully specify what I mean by what we
mean by a graph so a directed graph G
usually denoted s G is a pair of two
sets the same V which is a set of
vertices finite and E the set of edges
which is each edge is a pair of vertices
so a directed graph is one in which the
edges have directions going from one
vertex to the next an undirected graph
is the same thing but the edges do not
have directions so we can in the bottom
graph we can go from node 1 to node 2
and we can also go from node 2 to node 1
in the graph is the same thing as a
network we also use interchangeably
nodes and vertices and edges is the same
thing as links also the same thing is
arcs and so here is one abstraction of a
transportation graph that's a graph that
gives rise to brace paradox that I'll
touch upon later so we have four nodes
edges between them and each Edge has
cost which in this case denotes the
travel time going from one node to the
next when I started trying to get into
the energy domain there I saw graphs
that look like that and this led to a
lot of confusion so to a power systems
person probably this is the bread and
butter and this is a very simple
electricity network but but to me it
isn't so you know they have these things
that they call buses and to me a bus is
a public transport vehicle it took me a
while to figure out that a bus I can
safely call a node in my language and I
still haven't quite figured out what a
line is whether it's an edge or a
sequence of edges but I have a semester
here to figure that out but to me in
order to be able to make some progress
on any of those electricity networks I
need to see something like the graph one
on the left so I really need to see
nodes that look like circles or points
in edges that are just simple segments
lines that connect those nodes and in
this case each Edge has characteristics
resistances line capacities and so on
dates are specified as edge costs so I
believe that just this representation
alone presents a big challenge for
computer science tyr is entering the
energy domain
hopefully will resolve this and many
other challenges in the rest of this
semester so back to shortest paths I
want to talk a little bit more about the
algorithm first of all what is
interesting algorithmically what is the
algorithmic challenge even in a very
simple graph like the one on the top
where you have n vertices any hindered
in a line in a sequence and each two
consecutive vertices have two possible
ways of getting from one to the next if
I were to find the shortest path from V
1 to V n I could use a brute force
approach that's usually the first thing
that we like to think of as algorithms
the most naive algorithm possible so
here the brute force approach would
enumerate all possible paths starting
with the one that takes all the top
links and maybe one bottom in multiple
top links and so on but this leads to
having two to the N possible paths and
these are too many so whenever you see a
number that is 2 to the N there is
somewhat of a scary number to an
algorithmic such as myself so we don't
like seeing numbers like that to us this
would lead to a very inefficient
algorithm so we call this listing
enumerating those paths would lead to an
exponential running time and why is this
number so huge just to contrast 10 to
the power 67 is the number of atoms in
our galaxy so we want to stay away from
number set from well from running times
that are exponential like that
well you might tell me there is
something smarter that you can do for
your graph on the top we don't need to
enumerate all these paths it's
sufficient to notice that going from v1
to v2 the bottom link is the faster one
going from v2 to v3 the top link is the
faster one and so on and chain this
together so that would lead to a much
faster algorithm that only has order of
running time of n the number of vertices
and indeed this is the secret to why the
shortest path problem is an easy one
algorithmically it's because it has this
property called optimal substructure
it's the property that in the graph on
the bottom if we want to go from A to C
and we find that the optimal route to do
that is the red one and then when we
just restrict going from A to B the
optimal still remains the red one in
other words if we take an optimal
solution and we take just a subset a
small part of this optimal optimal
solution it would remain optimal for
that corresponding smaller sub-problem
and not show this paths are not as
straightforward there's the graph on the
top because we might not be able to
separate the graphs cleanly into
independent parts if we have a graph
like that we can't really do that but
still Dijkstra's algorithm for example
starts out by finding from the source
what is the closest node to the source
so it finds that one and then it finds
the next closest node to the node we've
already found and so on and this is why
very informally we are able to solve
shortest paths efficiently so we are
able to efficiently so this is an
example of a greedy algorithm other
shortest path algorithms are examples of
dynamic programming algorithms and it's
just a list of types of algorithmic
techniques that we teach in
undergraduate algorithms course is
divided conquer linear programming and
so on and just to highlight again when
we don't know what to do we usually
resort to brute force or exhaustive
search and let me specify a little
further algorithm running times are
really important to us so we are always
after efficient algorithms or fast
algorithms but what do we mean by
efficient so we there was a lot of
thinking that went into that I imagine
it happened way before my time ideally
we want a definition of algorithm
efficiency that's platform-independent
in something independent enough
predictive value if we have increasing
instances how much does the algorithm
slow down and so this is the definition
it was arrived upon a few decades ago
that an algorithm is efficient if it has
polynomial running time so what's a
polynomial it's a mathematical
expression like the one right below so
this is a polynomial in one variable in
it's basically some number times n to
the power k plus another number times n
to the power K minus one and so on
there's a polynomial of degree K where K
some constant and we usually care about
asymptotic running time meaning is n
grows very large those second-order
terms will become dwarfed by the highest
one and so we typically represent the
running time by the highest order term
we say that our algorithm is order n to
the K where K is a constant so when we
talk about polynomial running times it's
simply order n to the power K for some
number K and so one example of a
polynomial running time is n to the 100
even though to you that may seem like
really bad running time in it it
probably is for for Big M on the other
hand an expression like the blue one
into the power 1 plus 0.2 log n is not
polynomial this is bigger than
polynomial so this is this would be
considered an inner fish
algorithm and four notes to begin this
is probably much better than into the
100 so there is some debate between what
efficient algorithms meaning theory and
what they mean in practice there is not
always a one-to-one match is another
well-known example the simplex algorithm
which is the most used algorithm for
linear programming hears exponential
worst-case running time while we do have
an efficient algorithm it runs in
polynomial time for linear programming
but let's not consider the practical one
so there are some disparities between
theory and practice here but generally
polynomial has stood the test of time
and has turned out to have a good
indication and one advantage to it is
also that the definition is easily
negate Abel meaning I can tell you
what's inefficient as well something
that trans that takes longer than
polynomial time so that brings me to our
most famous problem P versus NP P is the
class of problems that can be solved in
polynomial time in other words we can
give efficient algorithms for them NP
contrary to popular belief that means
non polynomial it it stands for a non
deterministic polynomial and it stands
for the class of problems for which we
can verify that the given solution is
correct in polynomial time and
specifically P is a subset of P and here
I want to insert many thanks to the help
of my PhD student Ali who is here in the
audience and here at Simons this
semester for the many beautiful pictures
that you see on these slides so this
picture is due to him is one example of
a polynomial time solvable problem we
have Rubik's Cube ordering an N by n by
n Rubik's Cube admits an efficient
algorithm so doko on the other hand is
not known to admit an efficient
algorithm however if you give me an
answer to Sudoku I can quickly check I
can add up the numbers and verify that
your solution is correct so so doc with
an example of a problem in NP and there
are many other problems beyond MP for
example chess if you tell me what is my
next optimal move I cannot verify that
in polynomial time but in any case we a
lot of our tools are for problems in P
and in NP and a lot of the problems in
the real world fall in this category so
that's what I'll focus on problems with
in P and NP so let me clarify further
this difference between what it means to
solve a problem and what it means to
verify a candidate solution in
polynomial time so for example back to
shortest paths is there a path in graph
G from a given source node to a given
destination node with at most K edges
for example down on the bottom I may ask
you is there a path with the most size
edges and you may take some time to look
at this graph and try to solve it well
again that's a shortest path so that's
an easy problem algorithmically and
verifying a solution is even easier if I
give you a path you can see that it
indeed has five edges so the answer is
yes so I can verify the solution much
easier than I I can find it I can solve
for it back to travelling salesman in a
related problem Hamiltonian cycle so
Hamiltonian cycle in an undirected graph
is a cycle that visits every vertex
exactly once and for solving a problem
here is a problem is there a Hamiltonian
cycle in a given graph G so you see the
graph on the Left gives you one in which
there is such a cycle and the one on the
right there isn't such a cycle so this
is a is a hard problem if you give me if
if you give me a graph it will be hard
for me to come up with a cycle or you
know just
answer whether there is a cycle or there
isn't but once you give me a cycle I can
easily verify that such a cycle indeed
exists and currently even though
verifying a given solution that the
given solution is correct seems like a
much easier problem than solving the
problem in the first place no one has
been able to prove that it is easier and
so this is informally our biggest open
question whether P is equal to NP so
it's a class of polynomially solvable
problems the same as the class of those
problems for which we can verify a given
solution in polynomial time or not and
given that we don't know the status we
go on to further categorize problems in
NP such as the np-complete problems so
np-complete problems are informally the
hardest problems in NP and they have a
property that if any np-complete problem
can be solved in polynomial time then
all of them can be solved in polynomial
time so if someone tries to prove that P
is equal to NP all you need to do is
find one np-complete problem that you
really like and you'll find that you're
able to think about and come up with a
clever efficient algorithm for it and
you will have resolved the biggest open
problem in theoretical computer science
and a little further on np-complete
problems so slightly more formally a
decision problem one to which the answer
is yes or no is np-complete if it is U
and P so we can verify it's a give a
solution is correct in polynomial time
and it is at least as hard as some known
np-complete problems so we have a strict
way of defining mathematically the
notion of at least is hard but it says
as far as I'll go and so to prove that a
problem is np-complete we just have to
find another known np-complete problem
so that our problem is at least as hard
and every problem was shown to be
np-complete in the same
except for the very first epic ability
problem which was a real breakthrough
but it means that from any problems we
show is np-complete we can trace back a
path down to that first one and all of
these steps were very precise
algorithmic transformations and this is
why if you find just a single and we
complete problem and give a polynomial
time algorithm for it you'll at once
have solved all of the known np-complete
problems and so when this is very deeply
ingrained in us as theoretical computer
scientists when we see a new problem a
well specified algorithmic problem the
first thing that we want to understand
is whether this problem is in P does it
admit an efficient algorithm or if it's
or is it np-complete or or in some other
complexity class and there are many
other complexity classes I will just
stick to P and NP complete but just so
you see this is a very small sample of
the many complexity classes that exist
so you see P in red and MP in yellow
there is also randomized polynomial time
exponential time exponential space and
so on and if you're more interested I
would invite you to google complexity zu
there is a web page on Wikipedia which
details the many many complexity classes
and the relations to them and so this is
part of research on computational
complexity is to understand the
relations between different complexity
classes so the P versus NP problem is
not just an open problem in theoretical
computer science it's now being listed
as one of the millennium prize problems
by the clay mathematics Institute so you
see it appear down here is just a
portion of the website and there are
four more problems down below P versus
NP but you see that appear is problem
number three if you click on it you will
find more detail about the problem so
each of those seven problems known as
Millennium
problems will get a reward of 1 million
dollars if you come up with a solution
for them so it's now considered there's
very fundamental and important problem
in mathematics as well but it's not just
a problem of great theoretical interest
it's also great practical importance
because if you prove that your problem
is np-complete that means that you
shouldn't waste time looking for an
efficient algorithm well unless you're
really passionate about it
maybe you'll find one in which case you
have a you will have revolutionized the
area of theoretical computer science in
mathematics but typically if you
encounter an np-complete problem then
again we don't just stop there we look
for efficient approximations heuristics
and so on and what do I mean by
efficient approximation so an
approximation algorithm is a polynomial
time algorithm which doesn't give us the
exact answer but it maybe gives us a
near optimal answer and we like to
understand how much near the optimal we
are and so formally an alpha
approximation algorithm for an
optimization problem is one that runs in
polynomial time returns a correct
solution beta at or or some other
combinatorial object and the cost of
this solution is at most alpha times the
cost of the optimum so even though we we
don't know how to find the optimum we
can guarantee that we'll be that far
from it and it's an example back to the
Traveling Salesman problem which I
mentioned at the beginning in which I
said is hard so it's a known np-complete
problem that's the formal description of
the problem again you just need to find
a tour of the cities or addresses for
UPS delivery so as to minimize the
distance or in the decision version so
that your distance is at most some
budgets be to be traveled so just to
mention this problem is
in NP because if you give me a tour I
can add up the distances and verify that
they add up to no more than my desired
budget my total travel time and so if
I'm given a version of this problem
metric TSP here's a set of cities and
distances that satisfy triangle
inequality that simply means that going
from City a to city B will take you no
longer than the centricity C on the way
and one way to approximate this problem
since we don't know how to solve it
exactly in polynomial time is to to find
what's called the spanning tree a
spanning tree is just a set of edges
that form a connected graph there is no
loop there is no cycle so an example of
a spanning tree is the set of edges that
are in bold black on the figure so we
find the minimum spanning tree one with
total minimum edge cost and then we just
go around it twice and that gives us a
tour that gives us a little more than a
tour because we then end up visiting
some cities more than once and to
prevent from doing that we just once we
get to a city for a second time we just
skip that city and move on to the next
one so we eliminate those repetitions
and we end up with a tour and this tour
turns out to be a to approximation
algorithm for the Traveling Salesman
problem because any tour would cost more
than a minimum spanning tree and paying
twice the cost of minimum spanning trees
would guarantee us to be no more than
twice the cost of the optimal tour if
you missed the last part don't worry
about it
what I wanted to illustrate mainly is
what we mean by approximation algorithms
and to give you just a brief example of
a cute approximation algorithm that they
fairly easy for a really important
problem the Traveling Salesman problem
so I started out with shortest paths and
the shortest paths is my running example
for the entire presentation as I said
the truth is parts are easy however
they're only easy if you abstract away
the realistic challenges that may be
your optimal route doesn't just depend
on where you go but also where everybody
else goes and so this means that in
addition to thinking about how to
computer these parts algorithmically we
need to also worry about strategic
considerations how would other people
affect the outcome that we see the
length of our shortest path okay so this
brings us to again a really brief
tasting of game theory so game theory
unlike what many people think that they
link them to video games they have not
much to do with video games but it's
it's a mathematical field which studies
the strategic interaction of people and
one way to think of games is as thought
experiments which help us learn how to
predict rational behavior in situations
of conflict and this is what I mean by
those three highlighted colored phrases
by situation of conflict I mean that
everybody's actions affect all the
others rational behavior means that I is
a participant in the game simply care to
optimize my own benefit so games
rational behavior doesn't capture
altruism and be another such human
behaviour and by predicting I want to
know what what is the outcome of a game
so when people interact in a certain way
what will happen at the end those
predictions are called solution concepts
and the most famous such solution
concept is the Nash equilibrium there
are many others and so back to through
the sports now that additionally capture
this strategic interaction through
congestion so the reason we have to
worry about others what parts others
will select is this phenomenon of
congestion which basically means that
the roads are shared resources and the
more people use a given road or a given
edge in a network the travel time tends
to increase and this congestion
phenomenon has unfortunately led to a
lot of waste of time and fuel captured
by congestion costs that were measured
to be a hundred sixteen billion dollars
in 2014 so this is why transportation is
such a prominent area I think in this
program and it's labeled one of the
areas of national priority to improve so
game theory provides us a way to
understand congestion and hopefully
again give us some insight on how we can
alleviate congestion that's why we study
them and they'll illustrate I won't give
an overview of game theory as a whole
but I will focus on congestion games so
through an example to start with suppose
that we have 100 drivers that want to go
from town a to town B and I have
captured this congestion phenomenon the
fact that travel time increases if more
people use a given link by giving this
variable X appear is a in the travel
time on some of the edges so X here
stands for the number of drivers that go
on this particular link and so if I have
all 100 drivers go on the first link on
the top that means that this link will
take one hour to traverse whereas if 50
drivers go on the top link then I will
everyone will experience the delay of
half an hour so again this is just an
abstraction so two links you have this
congestion effect and the other to take
always one hour they don't suffer from
this congestion phenomenon
and the question is what would be the
resulting traffic pattern in the
situation and probably everyone can spot
quickly that those 100 drivers would
split 50-50 so 50 drivers will go on the
top and 50 drivers will go on the bottom
and this will be an equilibrium
situation because in this in this way
everyone travels one and a half hours
there is no incentive for anyone to
switch to the other out because it takes
the same amount of time
in contrast any unbalanced traffic
pattern if I had 40 60 45 60 and so on
one of the routes would take shorter
than the other Amen people would have
incentive to switch so that would not be
an equilibrium situation well notice
that in this traffic pattern the two
bolded links would take half an hour
each and suppose now that you have a
benevolent mayor who wants to improve
efficiency in the transportation network
so they decide to connect those two
faster segments to make it faster for
everyone to reach from town a to town B
so they build a superhighway that takes
zero hours connecting those two vertical
links and all of a sudden now the super
highway becomes beneficial for everyone
to use so everyone switches to use the
zigzag route indicated in light blue and
indeed this will be the resulting
traffic pattern the tundra dist traffic
pattern when all 100 drivers take the
first top link this top link now would
take one hour to traverse and same with
the last bottom link and so the total
delay that everyone experiences now is
two hours so instead of improving the
situation for everyone
situation became worse that's called
brace paradox the phenomenon that adding
a link in a network may
times deteriorate travel time so what
happened here is that let me first
actually verify for you that this will
be the result extracting pattern does
anyone have a question on that so
so it's an easy exercise to check
why wouldn't we have anyone go just on
the on the top or on the bottom root as
before well they would compare their
zigzag route with the alternative and
the non overlapping parts they would
compare x over 100 and 1 our x over 100
with 100 drivers is always less than or
equal to 1 our so switching to the top
or the bottom is won't give them any
benefit so everyone will stick to this
zigzag route this is the equilibrium
situation well of course they could do
it before and he have the 50-50 split
but it's not an equilibrium anymore but
it's it is what's called a socially
optimal traffic pattern the one that
minimizes total travel time and the fact
that equilibria may be inefficient and
here inefficient means something very
different from inefficient algorithms so
inefficiency of equilibria means how far
are you from a socially optimal
situation one that maximizes everyone's
total benefit here so so that's an
example how equilibria can be an
efficient so that's another challenge
beyond the computational one the
algorithms well here you see that the
equilibria is basically 33% more costly
then then the socially optimal traffic
pattern where everyone split half in
half and this was quantified as price of
energy so that's a measure of how
inefficient equilibria how far they are
from this socially optimal situation
formally defined as the performance of
the system in the worst Nash equilibrium
over the optimal performance
the one that would arise if a central
planner directed where everyone should
go so as to minimize total travel time
and just to revisit again so I'll give
definitions through pictures I had
previously have more mathematical
definitions and my students who listened
to my practice talk said no remove all
the math so word drop is the one who
studied this model of congestion games
and he came up with two principles the
first one was that travel times on used
roads should be all equal and no greater
than travel times on unused roads this
is essentially the definition of world
traffic WA Librium so he didn't call it
so but it acquired his name it's
equivalent to Nash equilibrium Nash was
working on his equilibrium concept in
parallel so those were around the same
time it's also called user equilibrium
and so again wardrobe equilibrium is a
traffic pattern where everyone travels
along shortest paths
so again an example of equilibrium here
is where everyone takes this zigzag
route and as we said this would not be a
socially optimal traffic pattern so that
was war drops second principle that the
average or total journey time should be
minimum well this is a desired traffic
pattern but not one that users would
arrive on their own to and it's known as
the social optimal so again that's a
traffic pattern that minimizes
everyone's total travel time and the
social optimum in this picture is the
one with the superhighway included is
the one where everyone splits 50/50 and
ends up traveling one and a half hours
on average and something that came out
of this framework very elegant
mathematical
derivation was the social optimum could
actually be seen as having a similar
definition to an equilibrium so rather
than saying the social optimal means
that one did minimizes total travel time
you could say luxury social optimum is a
traffic pattern under which modified
travel times on youth routes are the
shortest where the modification is the
addition of something to the travel
times this addition could be interpreted
as tolls so if we were to add those
tolls in green to the too fast links
from before if we edit one half to each
you can verify that this now is an
equilibrium where it wasn't whereas it
wasn't before and this allows for for an
interesting mechanism design
interpretation that if we add told to
the network appropriate tools we can
drive people a free will to reach on
their own the socially optimal traffic
pattern and that's indeed the goal of
mechanism design so mechanism design is
a sister field of game theory you can
think of it as the inverse of game
theory it's the study of how to design
the rules of the game so as to guide
people to an outcome that you want them
to reach such as the socially optimal
traffic pattern here and again just as a
reminder I mentioned them before but
price of Anarchy was a way a measure to
quantify how far equilibrium can be from
the social optimum it measures the
degradation of system performance due to
you can call it free wheeler or selfish
behavior whichever is your favorite
expression selfish behavior caught on as
an expression in in algorithmic game
theory it was measured it can be shown
with a very simple and elegant proof to
be 4/3 not only in the example we saw
here but
general graphs so long as the the delay
the travel time is a function of the
number of drivers on the link is linear
and you can derive those expressions for
other types of delay functions so just a
few takeaway points on congestion games
so I started out with my running example
shortest paths so I said sure this path
is an easy algorithmic problem but it
becomes more challenging when you think
of multiple users in a network all
sharing the same resource is the same
roads here fortunately congestion games
are one example where both the
equilibrium and the social optimum exist
and can be computed efficiently via
convex programs in general game theory
this is one big challenge so you know
game theory model the first thing you
want to establish is whether an
equilibrium exists and if so can you
compute it in algorithmic game theory so
here we can compute them and the good
news is that not only can we compute
them but we can arrive it so it's a
social optimal if we introduced this
additional modified travel times which
we can interpret the stalls or or some
other mechanisms in again price of
energy is a quantification of the
inefficiency of equilibrium and it can
help guide us whether an intervention in
a system is necessary by way of
mechanism design is always to guide
people to a more optimal outcome so
another one complication of first path
is when you have multiple people when
you have strategic behavior another
complication is when you have uncertain
travel times so we are slowly studying
to add more practical considerations to
the problems
so if we have uncertainty here is a toy
example what
would be the shortest path here Oh
surely this path is not well-defined
first of all so let's say we are going
to the airport and we can either take
birds that let's say there's no need to
any congestion issues and always takes
40 minutes or we can take a cab which
again to simplify will take half an hour
or 60 minutes with probability half in
half so which which route would you
prefer I haven't specified the problem
fully so if I were inhibition to tell
you that your for your flight you have
to be at the airport by 10:30 a.m.
now that might give a little more
insight or if you read if you leave
before 9:50 if you give yourself more
than 40 minutes for your trip then the
BART option seems like a sure thing the
better option because you give there
100% on time however if you forgot your
passport or other documents ran home and
now all of a sudden it's 950 - the BART
option will get you're late for sure and
so now your only chance of getting to
the airport on time is the road by cab
even though it gives you only 50% of the
being there on time and so the notion of
optimality here differs so shortest
paths are not well defined under
uncertainty you have to come up with
some kind of objective function and here
our objective is to arrive to the
airport on time or minimize our
probability of being late and this is a
result of risk aversion so when we
encounter risk oftentimes we we we
risk-averse and this would bring me to
what we mean by risk how we define risk
but just again Toto to conclude this
example risk critically affects how we
define what an optimal route means and
sometimes being risk averse
we may be 14 to choosing a risk loving
situation the taxi the road by taxi has
both higher meaning higher
so we may be forced into a gamble
because this is the only option - that
gives us some positive probability of
arriving on time and so that's why I
talk about risk risk and critically
affect our design of algorithms were
analysis of game theory models in
mechanism design so a little bit more on
so what is risk so everyone informally
understands risk but mathematically
there is no one agreed-upon definition
of risk so it's it depends on the
application it depends on the situation
and here I will just mention very
briefly different approaches of
quantifying risk from different fields
economics financing in modern risk
theory so in economics risk is captured
or measured through expected utility
theory so the idea that you can express
preferences over random variables or
lotteries by mapping each one to a
single number through what's known a
utility function that's a very old
concept that predates expected utility
Theory Bernoulli in 1738 already had
suggested that and such a utility though
exists if you assume given axioms I
won't go into a definitions of those
axioms and it turns out that those
axioms fail in reality so expected
utility theory doesn't necessarily
capture how people actually behave
though we still it's a useful
prescriptive theory so where it fails
these people are given these experiments
so in the first situation a group of
people will ask to choose between a
lottery that gives them fifty five
thousand dollars think of it as your
and your salary with probability 33% or
$48,000 with probability 66% and zero
with a small 1% probability so either
choose that or choose $48,000 for sure
so which one would you choose
we can do a poll of hands in this room
who would go for option one there's a
lot of various clothing people here
maybe you your income is a lot higher
than these numbers who would go for
option two so in the experiment that was
performed here I saw roughly close show
heads but in the experiment it was
performed most people tended to choose
the sure thing the $48,000 and when the
same group of people was asked to choose
between a modified problem in the second
the second situation here so either get
fifty five thousand dollars with
probability thirty three percent zero
otherwise or for the eight thousand
dollars with probability 34 percent zero
otherwise
most people who had previously chosen
this sure thing the 48 thousand dollars
now chose the 55 thousand dollars to
them a 1% difference in the winnings
didn't make much difference in $55,000
looked much better well this is a
contradiction with expected utility
theory because if you try to map that
mathematically to a utility function to
be able to derive the resulting
preferences you'll arrive at a
contradiction that no such utility
function exists that's a that's a
contradiction with this independence
axiom in any case so these are
well-known criticisms of expected
utility theory but it's still a good
prescriptive theory that is one way of
capturing and defining a risk aversion
or risk loving behavior so for example
we convex utility functions are used to
represent risk-loving preferences and
concave utility functions are used to
represent risk-averse preferences
in finance a different approach was
taken independently so Markovic who was
the first one to quantify risk portfolio
identified risk with the variance of a
portfolio and postulated that you if you
want to minimize risk you should
minimize the variance of your portfolio
subject to some threshold that you want
to achieve on your return
so in shortest paths were running
example that would mean some some
examples under this framework would be
minimize the mean plus standard
deviation of travel times so that could
be one definition of risk-averse
shortest path another one could be
minimize minimize the variance such that
the mean is at most a given threshold or
minimize how much time you allocate for
your trip such that the probability that
you exceed that is no more than let's
say 5% so this is the well-known Value
at Risk criterion that's used widely by
financial institutions and multiple
others that fall under this framework
but basically they're all involve some
combination of mean and variance and
some of the criticisms of this year is
that it may lead to non monotonic
paradoxical preferences for example if
you have two parts to choose between one
always takes one hour the other one
takes always one hour or 50 minutes the
second one is strictly better however
the second one is penalized by this
objective function at the top because it
has a positive standard deviation so it
will end up having a bigger risk
according to that definition also non
convexity which which some people linked
to risk diversification and so as a
result of those criticisms modern risk
theory was developed axiomatically where
researchers stated what our desired
axioms for risk aversion and not to go
through them but just one example of
this is the conditional Value at Risk
I mentioned the value at risk being how
much time do you budget for your trip so
that the probability of being late is at
most 5% well here in the conditional
Value at Risk we don't just care to
minimize that threshold probability
we're late with most 5% but how much
late we are beyond the threshold matters
so we want to minimize the expectation
of lateness the expectation of that
probability tail and just one remark
that when a random variable is normally
distributed with conditional value at
risk which is not one key such called
coherent risk measure satisfying those
axioms is actually equal to the mean
standard deviation so back to algorithms
so what definitions of risk should we
use for our algorithmic formulations
well it depends on the situation and we
really can't use all of them at once
they all would require different
algorithmic approaches because they have
different mathematical properties but
pretty much all of them lead to a new
challenge with shortest paths for
example I mentioned that there's an easy
algorithmic problem because of optimal
substructure the fact that if the
optimal route from A to C is the red one
the optimal route from A to B is still
the red one so this no longer holds if
you for example want to arrive to the
airport on time or if you want to
minimize the mean plus standard
deviation of your path so if you want to
minimize the mean plus standard
deviation of your path if you are just
going from node a to node B you can add
up the numbers and see that from A to B
the better option is the blue link meter
as a total seven point nine versus eight
and if you do the calculations going
from A to C the better path would be the
red one so we now see that a track
portion of an optimal solution is no
longer optimal for the smaller problem
and we cannot use dynamic programming
and basically the approaches that allow
for efficient
rhythms and the challenge here is really
that we are going from originally a
linear objective function for shortest
paths to now a nonlinear in this case
it's even non convex objective this
means standard deviation risk objective
so what could we do just to give a
little glimpse in this case it's a very
different algorithm and the key insights
are three is one is to map your whole
problem onto the mean variance plane
that means represent all my feasible
path says red dots on this diagram so
it's red dot corresponds to a path with
x-coordinate equal to its mean travel
time and y-coordinate equal to
experience and then observing also the
visualization of the objective function
through those parabolas that you see how
your objective function value higher
mean standard deviation corresponds to a
higher parabola so the best path is the
red point that lies on the lowest
possible parabola the one that touches
over there and so how do we find that
path well we can't really find it we
don't know how to find it efficiently
that's an open theoretical problem but
we can enumerate all the candidates all
the paths with mean variance they're
sort of on the lower left and pick the
best one of them this leads to an
algorithm that here's running time into
the login and if you remember definition
of efficiency that's not pouring on me
all that's higher than polynomial so
it's not considered an efficient
algorithm it's also likely not
np-complete because it's less than
exponential time so it's still an open
trouble that's intriguing to me
personally whether this problem is in P
or not in any case there are ways around
this inefficient worst-case running time
by approximation so we can approximate
this arbitrarily well and find the path
that's arbitrarily close to the optimal
path
and we can do so for not just
shortest-path but for various
combinatorial problems and several
related risk averse objectives and here
I want to mention that even though I'm
talking about risk the main challenge is
that we transfer the uncertainty and
risk into a nonlinear objective so many
problems that are traditional in
algorithms are linear and with risk they
they become nonlinear non convex and
that's just an example of a problem that
we arrived upon that I find really
interesting in the power grid it's
basically finding a spanning tree with a
nonlinear objective I'm not going to
explain it so very interesting
algorithmically what about game theory
how does this change the congestion game
model that I told you so
previously I said that equilibrium is at
most four thirds higher cost than the
social optimum so at most you end up
travelling 33% more in total travel time
well if you add uncertainty now when you
consider different risk averse
objectives captured by those different
list of models their worlds have a
savage and so on so these are different
risk-averse objectives the price of
Anarchy would be very different
so that takeaway from this slide is that
you may end up having very different
numbers for the prediction of your
system performance from small constant
to unbounded and so the takeaway from
this slide is that risk very much
affects the predictions of system
performance so we need to be very
careful how we model risk and
incorporate it in further how we analyze
things where risk may become more
challenging here we were interested in
understanding how much risk alone
contributes to the degradation of system
performance to increase travel time of
commuters then selfish behavior alone
and so we thought of comparing the
risk-averse equilibria
one in which users select minimum risk
parts versus the risk neutral
equilibrium one in which users just
minimize their expected travel time and
we're going to see how much longer in
total those risk-averse users travel and
so they end up travelling more by this
factor over here in the highlighted
yellow box so to me that was interesting
algorithmically because the answer
depended on the network topology so this
EDA is something that depends on the
network topology one for series parallel
graphs two for the brace graph and up to
number of nodes over two for general
graphs or is the level of risk aversion
of people in k over there is how much
bigger the variance is compared to the
mean and let me mention just one slide
on mechanism design how risk changes
changes things there so yesterday we we
heard a fascinating experiment that
Balaji did with the outcome that people
tend to respond much better to lotteries
so we heard the example for those of you
who didn't hear in recycling for example
if you get five cents to return the
bottle versus if you are promised to get
$100 with a small probability people
will end up recycling more if they give
this lottery so this captures the fact
that for small amounts of money people
tend to be risk-loving so they respond
better to lotteries well it turns out
this is really not well understood in
theoretical mechanism design so what are
the optimal lotteries should I offer you
$100 with a small probability should I
offer you a basket of options 100 with a
certain 50 with another if so on that's
not well understood so we are currently
studying that with with my postdoc
management Iraqis who is a fellow here
in the program and he is extremely well
knowledgable
both on this and he's worked on
mechanism design with risk-averse
agent so I encourage you to talk to him
more for more details but let me
conclude so I attempted to give a taste
of the types of tools we have in
theoretical computer science and in what
we find intellectually stimulating and
my hope from this program is that we we
have a dialogue with researchers outside
theoretical computer science beats other
theoreticians or experts from our
domains Natural Sciences energy
transportation where I hope for a
win-win situation but the situation is
not easy so we theoretically computer
scientists want to somehow abstract
clean formulations from from the more
practical problems and I think in turn
we have a lot to offer we have a lot of
tools in a way of thinking that would
provide the insight into hopefully
solving some of the the more practical
problems I won't mention open questions
there are many but only four for this
semester long program taught to ask the
questions thank you very much
questions
yes many comment just regarding
real-time systems most of the definition
of efficiency of algorithms are for 70s
and 80s then today for example the input
is not of size n just an infant stream
especially in real-time decision making
and when we walk with you already single
for the brain N squared and 2 to the end
it's the same thing it's totally
impractical we need actually linear time
near linear or as well even talking to
in the next recitation we actually
usually of of image much too much
we need some linear time and another
thing is that we have the brows so
communication issues and parameters are
also now very important not just a
running time and maybe dusting I think
the most important thing is development
time we state is more even than running
time sometimes with time so there is the
running time if it's very slow say 10
times what you want just by thing
computers on the cloud and it's 10 times
faster but the development time finding
time student this stuff why is something
much harder than funny 10 computers is
still possible that if you look time to
implement algorithms Soviet and organic
wheat which is trivial a few lines and
off another go it'll be 10 page that
will take years to implement and then
the constants can kill you so so that's
that's other on the battle or the
project beside the big data in real time
we do not support the augmentation
because once people say that you know is
to write in c compared to fight on the
constants are very important and the
whole nation kills it but when you
handle big data and is really really
very large leaf in it so the old
notation makes sense and you know they
don't care too much about the constants
and again if it's slow the constant just
by a constant number of computers on the
cloud and you can heal this constant but
good things in that the class definition
but some also updated rotations
thank you for the comments I think that
is an excellent way of starting a
dialogue and a great preview to the next
to the next thought yes first braises
paradox a beautiful idea and intriguing
and engrossing but when you begin to try
to apply it to actual transportation
networks I didn't have to confront the
fact that we don't actually have roads
that have zero travel time or we're
roads that have no sensitivity to
congestion and I have tried in various
ways to find a way of an intermediate
way between the abstraction and the
messiness of actuals highways connected
yeah interesting results but nothing
that's provable or or even readily
expressible in in some closed form but
obviously you know if this is to be a
practical use you have to find some way
to map from the real world to those
abstractions can you offer us any
guidance on how to make progress in that
direction well let me repeat the
question so the comment that brace
paradox that I showed is a nice cute
mathematical model yet how does it map
in practice while I will not tell you I
will not want to attempt to tell you
right now how to go from this theory to
practice
I will defer to some of my
transportation colleagues who have a lot
of insights but I will say that brace
paradox does arise in practice with just
a curious anecdote I read I think the
New York Times how at some point brought
away a portion of Broadway was closed in
Manhattan and everyone feared that this
would lead to tremendous congestion and
once it was closed down traffic flowing
truth so the New York Times account of
that is the only extant publication on
that observation and there was
absolutely no before-and-after
documentation there were no counts of
actual travel times or anything it was
an offhand observation by a traffic
engineer there was a paper nine that
said that this this kind of phenomena
was observed in back then yes and in
some other cities as well it's a 2009
paper yes and it's also whacking them
verification okay just at that point in
the context of verax paradox not in the
context of transportation but in the
context of power grid there has been
numerous such incidences in the context
of what they were trying to expand the
power grid for example to accommodate
more renewables in West Texas or coastal
California with the good intention of
strengthening the arbitrary power
transmission line may lead to a
unintended consequence of reduced
network capacity and there are many
other examples that we have to show you
apply yes over there
so I fully understand that you seem to
be stating a theorem I think that you
could take any transportation network
and add constant toes on various links
to ensure that they fully reimburse the
social optimum is that correct that's
correct I didn't put forward the precise
mathematical statement okay let's take
our break and resume at 11 o'clock for
will beat stop